Depression is a disorder that afflicts over 10% of the world's population,...
...but we as a society know little about it.
Stereotypes tell us that depressed people are weak,...
...unless they happen to be a tortured artist.
It can be difficult to understand depression because it's invisible.
It's a disorder defined by thoughts, behaviors, and feelings...
...rather than obvious symptoms like vomiting, rashes, or fever.
Those who have experienced depression...
...are all too familiar with comments from misguided friends such as:...
..."Snap out of it" or "Just get up and do something."
Even those with depression...
...might have a hard time understanding what they are experiencing,...
...and they often blame themselves for not being able to snap out of it.
To understand what depression really is, we need to talk about symptoms.
First of all, depression has symptoms related to how someone feels.
These symptoms include nearly constant feelings of sadness, anger, guilt, or hopelessness.
Next, there are symptoms related to behavior.
They include social withdrawal, a lack of energy, low motivation,...
...poor concentration, sleep problems, or significant changes in appetite.
Finally, symptoms related to thoughts include poor self-esteem,...
...thoughts of suicide, and loss of interest in regular activities.
Symptoms of depression must last at least one week, and they are often cyclical.
This means that the symptoms can come and go over a period of months or years.
A person who experiences depression once is likely to have future episodes.